bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
dans savouregarde au sommaire ce soir un
sujet potentiellement explosif dans
beaucoup de villes en France les aides
FE3 lettres pour zone affaiblissement
peut-on interdire les voitures
polluantes en ville sans exclure toute
une partie de la population le RN a bien
une réponse c'est non le parti de Marine
Le Pen propose tout simplement de
supprimer les ZFE on en débat dans cette
émission notre grand témoin ce soir
Alice Eeckman spécialiste de la Chine
son dernier ouvrage décortique la
stratégie implacable mise en oeuvre par
Pékin pour imposer la Chine comme la
première puissance mondiale enfin nos
affranchis ce soir on reviendra sur
l'affaire Adrien catenens avec Marco
pommier la taxe carbone aux frontières
de l'Europe avec Fanny guinochet enfin
l'impossible plan de paix en Ukraine
avec Isabelle Lasserre voilà pour le
sommaire place au débat dans sa Burgard
[Musique]
ZFE derrière ces trois lettres se
cachent donc une révolution à court
terme dans nos modes de déplacement nos
modes de vie 40% de la population
devrait être concerné par ces zones à
faible émission dès 2025 alors comment
faire pour que ces ZF ne deviennent pas
des zones à forte exclusion et bien pour
en débattre j'accueille sur ce plateau
Lisabelle ouko bonsoir vous êtes députés
européens de la Vienne Bruno millienne
bonsoir député MoDem des Yvelines et
co-auteur d'un rapport sur la mise en
place de ces zona affaiblissement pierre
Merin bonsoir bonsoir rassemblement
national du Gard et vous vous êtes donc
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
du rassemblement national qui vise à
supprimer ces aid FFE enfin Fabrice
Godefroy nous rejoindra dans un instant
de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes opposant déclaré à ses
aid FFE et pour commencer et bien qui
d'autre que Stéphane blackovski pour
camper le décor
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes celles
qui nous regarde aussi et à tous donc
alors si j'ai bien compris Stéphane
alors si bien compris avant de se lancer
dans un débat sur les aider feu ce que
vous avez décidé à faire Clément je
pense qu'il faut quand même mieux
commencer par rappeler ce que c'est
qu'une zdfc parce que regardez ça c'est
un sondage qui date de février je suis
pas sûr que la connaissance est bien
progressée sur le sujet il y a la moitié
des Français quasiment qui n'ont jamais
entendu parler de ZF et puis pour
l'autre moitié qui a vaguement entendu
parler des et des feux il y en a que 37%
qui savent qu'ils savent expliquer de
quoi y retournent et donc on compte sur
vous Stéphane vous allez nous expliquer
alors moi ce matin j'étais Paris je
savais pas trop peut-être un manque de
pédagogie quelque part de gouvernement
j’accuse personne mais j'ai bossé donc
une ZF vous l'avez dit c'est zona faible
démission concrètement ça veut dire que
dans les deux ans à venir c'est à dire
d'ici 1er janvier 2025 dans 43 des plus
grandes villes de France les véhicules
les plus pollants n'auront plus le droit
de circuler pour certaines zones sous
peine une amende ça sera 68 euros si
vous payez pas tout de suite 45 si vous
payez tout de suite donc est-ce que je
suis concerné voilà vous vous demandez
ça regardez la carte alors on le sait
peut-être pas mais il y a déjà 11 ze qui
sont existants qui sont en bleu et il y
en a 32 de plus qui vont apparaître qui
elles sont en orange elles vont
apparaître d'ici le premier avril 2025
alors dites-nous quelles sont les
véhicules qui vont être interdits de
rouler dans ces villes alors tout ça
dépend de votre vignette critère petite
vignette que normalement vous devez
avoir coloré là avec un numéro vous
devez avoir sur votre pare-brise son
numérotées de 1 à 5 vous voyez un
tableau je vais vous montrer pour
essayer de faire un peu la répartition
ça va être progressif donc dès le 1er
janvier les critères 5 eux seront
interdits des élèves ensuite 1er janvier
2024 les critères 4 premier janvier 2025
les critères 3 ce qui fait que donc
d'ici à peu près deux ans et en gros 40%
des véhicules qui roulent aujourd'hui en
France qui pourront pas ou plus
difficilement accéder au centre-ville et
donc c'est pas rien et ça risque de
compliquer de pas mal de français alors
oui mais que voulez-vous Clément l'heure
est grave c'est une question de santé
publique on parle des particules fines
qui sont mises par les véhicules les
plus polluants et donc c'est mort
provoqué par ces particules fines ça
représente 10 fois le nombre de morts
sur la route donc forcément le ministre
s'inquiète on écoute Christophe Béchu
ministre de l'écologie
il y a 47000 morts en France à cause de
la pollution atmosphérique à cause du
dioxyde à cause des des particules fines
et ces concentrations elles sont où
elles sont dans les endroits qui sont
les plus urbains le sujet du
gouvernement c'est pas d'emmerder les
Français c'est pas de chercher une
nouvelle lubie pour faire en sorte de
les ennuyer c'est de préserver de
protéger les plus fragiles les personnes
âgées les enfants qui vivent dans ces
villes
donc là on dépasse sévère déjà sur le
scudy le ministre ça fait réagir en
plateau on entend bien qu'il s'agit de
sauver la vie d'enfant donc c'est quand
même difficile de s'opposer aux élèves
feu par rapport à cet argument mais le
gouvernement a l'air quand même un peu
embarrassé par exemple comment on va
contrôler les radins pour lire les
plaques d'immatriculation radar ou
paradar on écoute l'explication du
ministre il n'y aura pas de radar avant
au moins deux ans certains d'ailleurs
disent que ça va pas assez vite il y
aura des radars à l'entrée de Séville
non il y aura la possibilité pour les
mères qu'il souhaite d'acquérir des
radars dont on va établir la typologie
dans les années qui viennent et j'ai
bien compris il n'y aura pas de radar
mais il y en aura quand même un peu il y
en aura je crois que déjà c'est annoncé
à Lyon notamment dans d'autres villes
certainement aussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas très clair quand même oui
alors ce qui complique encore un petit
peu plus les choses c'est que le
gouvernement d'ailleurs ça brille un peu
derrière 100 jambes vous savez c'est pas
que nous on va déléguer ses
responsabilités aux collectivité
territoriales chacun des petits drapeaux
en fonction de ce qu'il veut donc voici
un nouveau tableau un peu plus compliqué
que le précédent donc chacun sera sommet
de reconnaître
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens dans une enfin beaucoup
de gens et des sondages qui disent un
tiers de la population de difficultés à
changer de véhicule on va voir les
chiffres on sait que le débat évidemment
est une aubaine pour le Front National
qui va défendre les automobilistes
rassemblement national
j'ai oublié bon en tout cas maintenant
que c'est corrigé
je vous laisse les battre merci beaucoup
Stéphane blackovski Bruno Milian on a
bien compris que l'objectif n'est pas
d'emmerder les Français on a vu aussi
que il y avait un risque quand même
d'une forme d'usine à gaz donc avant de
vous lancer là dedans avant de peut-être
vous mettre à dos une partie de la
population française est-ce que vous
êtes bien sûr de l'efficacité de ces ZF
sur cet objectif de santé publique oui
il y a des modélisations qui existent et
qui prouvent que effectivement si on
tient les délais on va réussir à faire
en sorte que nos villes n'aient plus le
taux de pollution qu'elles ont et
qu'elles soient en dessous des normes
demandées par l'Europe voire même en
dessous des normes demandées par l'OMS
donc il y a une vraie efficacité
aujourd'hui on a 48 000 morts à 47000
comme l'a dit de ministres 48000 morts
par an dus à la pollution atmosphérique
notamment les particules fines on y
reviendra je corrige deux trois choses
qui a pu dire Stéphane on nous a pas
confié une mission Gérard le seul et
moi-même nous sommes emparés de ce sujet
parce qu'on sentait bien qu'il y avait
un sujet qui montait sur les territoires
et qu'il fallait qu'on fasse le point
une photographie exacte à l'instant T de
ce qui se passait de ce qui était fait
de ce qui était pas fait de ce qui
restait à faire et de comment tenir les
engagements parce qu'au cours de ces
auditions et Dieu sait si on a passé
beaucoup de gens à la moulinette aucun
aucun de ceux qu'on a auditionné nous
ont dit qu'il fallait arrêter les anefeu
alors on va en débattre sur ce plateau
je me tourne d'abord vers vous pierre
Merin votre proposition de loi a été
examinée et rejeté ce matin en
commission elle sera tout de même
examinée dans l'hémicycle courant
janvier j'ai plus de 12 janvier
il s'agit de supprimer les ZFE est-ce
que ça veut dire vous êtes dans une
opposition de principe toutes les sont
forcément mauvaises à vos yeux alors
pour prendre pour essayer de prendre un
tout petit peu de hauteur il s'agit de
mettre en balance le principe de
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air et
de l'accessibilité sociale et de la
liberté de circulation
les feux sont et j'ai bien aimé la
présentation qui a été faite par votre
par votre confrère une usine à gaz mais
absolument absolument
total aujourd'hui la majorité se
réveille avec un système qu'il ne
maîtrise plus c'est-à-dire des aid des
feux qui sont complètement asymétriques
selon selon les choix politiques locaux
ce qui a été permis par la loi au niveau
national parce que le cadrage national a
permis aux élus locaux de faire quand
tout est décidé à Paris on dit que c'est
trop centralisé quand c'est les élus
locaux j'ai aussi important qui est
finalement d'altérer la liberté de
circulation moi je suis pas
décentralisation je m'étonne de ses
propos qui est la défense de la liberté
de circulation et la défense des
territoires ruraux pour pouvoir accéder
si vous voulez le principe de base c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les territoires ruraux
sont dévitalisés en termes de service
public en termes de service commerciaux
en termes d'emploi juste et donc ils ont
toutes formes de ZF ou pas soyez clair
bon on va être très clair je suis contre
le principe des aides je suis pour des
solutions alternatives pour
basculer les normes de qualité de l'air
dans les contrôles périodiques des
véhicules ça peut s'appeler contrôle
technique notamment mes améliorer les
contrôles techniques de ce point de
vue-là
50% les la baisse des particules fines
et de NOx qui sont les les les les les
les les émissions les plus toxiques pour
la santé on va quand même voir cette
photo vous avez posté sur Twitter qui
est devenu votre photo de profit vous
êtes venu devant l'Assemblée avec votre
306 S16 avec un message en PND à Anne
Hidalgo ça donne un peu l'impression que
votre sacro-sainte Peugeot bah ça passe
avant votre santé voir la santé de vos
enfants si vous en avez je sais pas j'ai
trois enfants et ça vous préoccupe pas
la pollution de l'air vous savez on
pourrait on pourrait discuter longtemps
de l'obsolescence programmée des
véhicules et du coup écologique des
véhicules qui doivent aller à la casse
le plus périodiquement possible un
véhicule pour vous et en discuter mais
un véhicule durable bien entretenu dont
on enlève la crasse du moteur il faut
pas il faut pas enlever en gros faut pas
s'attaquer faut pas s'attaquer aux
passionnés de véhicules anciens si vous
voulez oui les véhicules anciens sont
pas concernés par les adefs les
véhicules de collection ma 306 S16 est
largement concernée par les feux les
critères 3 si vous voulez donc elle est
la voiture de collection en tout cas ce
sont pas contre moi en l'occurrence
c'est pas une voiture de collection
c'est une voiture qui a 22 ans elle est
pas de de collection oui d'accord mais
pendant 8 ans elle est critère 3 donc
impossible d'accéder dans les centres
villes elle est propre elle est bien
entretenue elle est décalaminée et donc
elle pollue en moyenne bien moins qu'un
Range Rover qu'un Range Rover SUV dont
le coût écologique de la construction
est immense vous savez que les émissions
de particules fines au bout de 11000 km
pour les voitures neuves explose parce
qu'en fait les constructeurs brides
brident les normes à cause des normes
européennes et assez rapidement à
l'usage les les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de pardon de de particules de
dioxyde de carbone et de monoxyde et
d'oxyde d'azote explose en raison de
l'utilisation du véhicule et donc ce
véhicule à la 36 à 16 est bien moins
polluant qu'un Range Rover critère 1
Lisabelle ouko il y a 43 métropoles je
crois qu'ils vont être concernés par ces
zones à faible émission d'ici à 2025 ça
représente environ 40 % de la population
française c'est énorme ce matin en
commission il y a le député LFI Sylvain
carrière qui a demandé un moratoire pour
éviter que les plus pauvres ne soient
les premières victimes de ce dispositif
vous entendez c'est réticences face à
ces ce dispositif qui existe au sein
même de votre propre camp de la nuque
en fait il faut juste être un peu précis
d'ici 2025 les 32 nouvelles métropoles
qui vont être obligés c'est pas que des
métropoles mais les 32 agglomérations de
plus de 150 000 habitants qui vont être
obligés ne sont pas obligés d'exclure
directement les critères 3 4 5 ce ne
sont que celles qui sont en dépassement
régulier donc moi j'habite dans une
agglomération qui est Grand Poitiers qui
fait plus de 150 000 habitants qui n'a
pas de dépassement donc le la seule
obligation Cora Grand Poitiers c'est de
mettre en place un plan d'action pour
éviter que ça arrive justement pour
éviter qu'on arrive à des 2035 en
revanche là il y aura plus que du
critérin dans toutes les aides fe 32 32
32 32 à 113 donc en fait déjà c'est
c'est pas si excessif et c'est pas si
rapide que ça et ça prend en compte les
réalités locales j'entends les réserves
dans mon camp alors je suis pas soumise
je suis écologiste et vous savez qu'on a
parfois des divergences mais en tout cas
ce sur quoi on est d'accord et vous
aurez remarqué ce matin que les insoumis
ont voté de concert avec nous la
suppression des deux articles de la
proposition de loi du rassemblement
national ce que l'on entend c'est que il
faut mettre en place plus de mesures
d'accompagnement pour que le déploiement
des adefes passe au mieux et pour que
les automobilistes les plus précaires ne
soient pas dans leur capacités de
déplacement et c'est souvent pour aller
travailler enfin c'est souvent parce
qu'on n'a pas pris le problème à
l'envers est-ce qu'il fallait pas
d'abord prévoir ces solutions
alternatives avant de mettre en place
des solutions il y en a plein qui sont
sur la table elles sont pas compliquées
à mettre en oeuvre et et moi j'ai lu
attentivement le rapport de mon collègue
Bruno Millet qui propose des choses très
intéressantes et moi j'en retiens une
c'est le rétrofit en fait si on
développe la filière du rétrofit ça
permet à
transformer un véhicule thermique en soi
véhicules qui roule au gaz ou à
l'électricité
sans changer le véhicule lui-même
l'impact environnemental on a un paquet
écologique c'est très intéressant parce
qu'on n'a pas ce qui évoqué tout à
l'heure Pierre Morin qui est de
construire un nouveau véhicule
on garde la cascade carcasse on garde le
châssis on met un moteur plus performant
c'est très intéressant comme proposition
on peut le développer assez vite alors
il faut il faut structurer la filière on
sait que ça prend un peu de temps mais
c'est des emplois industriels locaux
enfin c'est on y gagne sur tous les
plans il y a aussi des choses qui ont
été proposées dans ce rapport c'est de
prendre en compte par exemple le poids
des véhicules effectivement un véhicule
d'aujourd'hui qui est énorme et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on porte depuis
longtemps avec les écologistes les très
gros SUV même s'ils sont très récents
polluent beaucoup plus qu'une petite
Clio de il y a 10 ans ou il y a 15 ans
donc ça aussi il faut que ce soit pris
en compte et peut-être que les critères
doivent être revus ou le mode
d'évaluation doit être revu mais c'est
propositions sont sur la table Fabrice
Godefroy nous a rejoints bonjour donc
vous êtes membre de l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes pour être
totalement transparent vous soutenez
cette proposition de loi du
rassemblement national si j'ai bien lu
un article du JDD qui explique que même
le délégué de l'association pierre
chasseret a participé à la rédaction
c'est qu'au niveau écologique on peut
quand même se poser quelques questions
quand même lesquelles bah c'est on est
en train de faire des lois gâchis des
lois anti-obsolescence programmées
qu'est-ce que c'est que les zones de
finition c'est une obsolescence
programmée qu'on est en train de mec
avec un système de vinaigre se
rétrophique
Renault le groupe très cher
tous les véhicules ne sont pas
homologués et c'est pareil il faut
pouvoir le changer c'est vraiment
marginal alors on va avant juste avant
de de se pencher un peu sur ce qu'on
pense les Français qui se vont être
concernés par ça j'aimerais juste savoir
vous votre position sur ces aides FFE
est-ce que c'est aussi une opposition de
principe vous êtes prêts à discuter de
modalités de mise en oeuvre de toute
façon c'est dans la loi climat et
résilience c'était d'abord dans la loi
l'homme dans la loi climat et résilience
donc il faut quand même le coup vous
êtes prêt à toute façon c'est dans la
loi il y a une chose qui est certaine
c'est que ça paraît pour l'instant
injouable et d'ailleurs je le vois bien
la métropole Grand Paris qui est la
ville enfin la métropole qui a le plus
avancé sur le calendrier ce qu'il y a le
calendrier minimum qui est dans la loi
c'est vrai c'est une réalité il y a ce
risque qu'on a évoqué en début
d'émission de ZF zona forte exclusion
Marion Becker journaliste LCP vous a
suivi Bruno Millien sur le terrain à la
rencontre justement des habitants de
votre circonscription et moi qu'on
puisse dire effectivement c'est que ce
sujet inquiète la population
les habitants de Mézières à 55 km de
Paris dans la circonscription du député
doivent déjà composer avec la ZF
parisienne
ici beaucoup travaillent à l'intérieur
et la plupart prennent leur voiture pour
s'y rendre
pour une au millième compte sur la
pédagogie pour la faire accepter
dans ces zones périphériques le sujet
sensible et inquiète
c'est une centaine de kilomètres tous
les jours entre ici la balle et
déplacements de clientèle
je vais de l'autre côté de Paris enfin
bon voilà je suis pleinement concernée
on en arrive même à faire du covoiturage
mais du coup c'est moi qui rapatrie tout
le monde je vais prendre tous ici et on
va ensemble travailler aujourd'hui si tu
dois changer de véhicule tu passerais à
l'électrique ou à l'hybride électrique
hors de question pourquoi je suis
parfois amené à faire des antennes de
kilomètres
et sincèrement je me vois pas
l'électrique pure je n'y vois pas et
avec nos revenus malheureusement on peut
pas se permettre d'aller vers des
véhicules neufs
vous ferez quoi malheureusement on
n'aura pas le choix comme tout le monde
ait trouvé notre alternative mais si
j'ai pas le choix bah soit je
démissionnerai soit transport en commun
mes amis c'est la même chose on en parle
parce qu'en fait ils disent on va
peut-être devoir quitter démissionné
parce qu'on ne pourra pas faire
autrement
on a bien eu conscience de tous les
freins qu'il y a et de l'explosion
sociale que ça pouvait être maintenant
le boulot qu'on a à faire
c'est d'arriver à trouver à tout le
monde une alternative à la voiture
pour accéder au train une heure et demie
à 2h de train
en voiture pour aller chez moi j'ai 80
km je mets une heure en ayant les
bouchons je comprends bien là pour le
coup les transports en commun c'est pas
la solution on sait qu'on a un vrai
problème de transport en commun si
demain on a des locations à des tarifs
relativement à la fois sur le électrique
c'est pas la solution j'ai bien entendu
mais au moins sur l'hybride est-ce que
ça c'est des solutions vous pourriez
prendre
oui on pourrait réfléchir tout le monde
est conscient que le reste à charge est
encore trop important et tout ça c'est à
l'étude au ministère et je pense que ça
va se faire assez rapidement de manière
à accélérer le mouvement
un message et des rencontres qu'il va
devoir multiplier s'il veut rassurer et
apaiser
vos administrés vous dire que pour
certains en tout cas il risque d'être
obligé de démissionner
vous ne répondez quoi il y aura une
alternative pour chaque cas de figure
c'est une c'est un engagement on a on a
un constat 48
000 morts par an dus à la pollution on
peut pas laisser ça en étant on a un
autre constat qu'on a fait avec Gérard
le seul je vous absolument
parce qu'on a travaillé même dans la
main dessus et nous on avait une petite
idée évidemment des points qui coincés
mais au fur et à mesure qu'on a fait les
auditions on a bien vu que c'était
beaucoup plus important que ça l'idée
c'est pas de dire on arrête ça c'est de
la différence qu'on a avec le
rassemblement national arrêtons ce qu'on
a mis en place non c'est de dire voilà
on a jusqu'à 2032 on va trouver des
solutions pour ne laisser personne au
bout de la route je vous en prends une
une seule parce que je pense que le
temps est compté et je ne connaissais
pas ce collectif avant que avant qu'il
vienne m'apporter son dossier c'est le
collectif roule qui est fait avec des
associations
solidaires comme le Secours catholique
ou le Secours populaire ou Emmaüs et les
garages solidaires c'est un réseau de
garagiste en France qui se sont dit et
là on va répondre du coup à
l'obsolescence programmée qui sont dit
ben écoutez il y a à peu près 1 million
200000 véhicules par an qui sont envoyés
à la casse c'est ce qu'on appelle les
véhicules hors d'usage dans ces
véhicules là il y en a qui sont roulants
il y en a qui sont roulants
reprenons-les
réhabilitons-les et mettons et
rétrophie-t-on les avec soit du
carburant moins polluant d'accord
bioéthanol Bessan tout ce que vous
voulez soit carrément à l'électrique le
reste à charge pour avoir un microcrédit
chez des gens qui sont dans la grande
précarité on a déjà discuté c'est 6000
euros maximum 6000 euros maximum sinon
vous n'avez pas votre crédit et bien
figurez-vous qu'avec le système de ce
collectif roule on sort un véhicule
électrique rétrophité à 7000 euros on en
est pas loin on peut le mettre en
leasing à 100 euros pour par mois il
peut être racheté au bout de cinq ans
mettre en place et les et les faire
prospérer et il y a pas que ça monsieur
milienne
très rapidement oui sur la solution de
l'éthanol les boîtiers éthanol voyez par
exemple si on a un boîtier éthanol
aujourd'hui vous avez une voiture avec
une vignette 3 ou 2 vous mettez un
boîtier éthanol ça ne note grade pas la
vignette donc vous ne rentrerez toujours
pas dans les zones
donc c'est un paradoxe c'est-à-dire que
la solution de l'éthanol effectivement
c'est une bonne solution mais on en
tient des choses qui peuvent être
débattues
c'est des choses qu'on peut améliorer
nous tout le problème est là en fait
c'est contrairement contrairement
nous on veut travailler avec les
collectivités et avec le gouvernement
améliorer les conditions non allez on a
réfléchi arrêtez vous dites pas que vous
réfléchi sur votre projet de loi il a
été prouvé ce matin que vous n'avez pas
besoin
au cas où juridique que vous avez
débattre je vais débattre avec les gens
qui savent parce qu'on a déjà débattu
bon attendez je vous remercie monsieur
attendez je vous remercie d'éviter
d'éviter votre condescendance et votre
maîtrise aujourd'hui c'est dans la loi
comme vous l'avez dit notre boulot c'est
quoi c'est évidemment d'arriver à ne
laisser personne sur le bord de la route
et qu'on réussisse ce Paris qui peut
paraître un pari fou je suis d'accord
avec vous mais on va mettre tout en
oeuvre pour y arriver il y a déjà des
mesures qui ont été prises ce fameux
collectif roule dont je vous parle donc
le gouvernement n'avait pas entendu
parler il se trouve que le lendemain du
jour où j'ai eu le le document le
document j'en ai au gouvernement ils se
sont déjà rencontrés avec le
gouvernement et j'attends un rendez-vous
pour qu'on puisse en discuter ensemble
je fais pas le tour
juste pour vous bien comprendre votre
démarche parce que il y a une échéance
il y a une échéance qui éclaire c'est la
fin du moteur thermique en Europe ça y
est la date elle est finie
pas intérêt à accompagner le mouvement
attendez quand on vous regarde vous
votre positionnement celui du RN oui oui
on peut se poser la question
opportuniste c'est pas du tout un
positionnement si vous voulez le parti
de la bagnole et fédérer tous les
mécontents voilà le parti de la bagnole
si vous voulez nous c'est très
intéressant ce qui est en train de se
passer puisque on voit aujourd'hui il y
a une mission flash pour dire il faut
éteindre le feu qu'on a créé nous-même
en fait vous réfléchissez après avoir
agi n'importe comment avec vos idées
feux vous avez fait n'importe quoi c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous avez créé un
dispositif c'est très simple ou les
maires les élus locaux peuvent faire
exactement les choses à leur sauce vous
avez ouvert une boîte de Pandore de
d'injustice sociale ou globalement
on vous écoute vous êtes pas vos
aujourd'hui vous avez pas mesuré
l'impact de la mesure qu'elle avait des
feux par rapport à l'acceptabilité
sociale et le sentiment de
stigmatisation d'infantilisation et de
culpabilisation des Français vous êtes
en train en fait de retourner
une bonne idée que la transition
écologique contre vous-même parce que
moi aussi je peux dire pas du tout si je
vais sur le terrain
je vais vous expliquer mon aller-retour
que j'ai sur le terrain c'est à dire que
les écolos pour les gens c'est c'est
péjoratif la transition écologique c'est
péjoratif on veut les exclure des
centres-villes on veut les exclure des
commodités
après il y a sauf que les gens les gens
m'expriment assez naturellement leurs
pensées ils ont pas besoin que je leur
fasse aussi le reportage et d'ailleurs
le reportage va largement pas du tout
dans votre sens d'ailleurs on a discuté
vous essayez d'endormir les gens en leur
disant oui on va tenter des trucs etc
dans vos solutions de votre mission
flash votre truc c'est de faire des
grandes consultations citoyenne mais il
aurait fallu le faire avant si vous
voulez aujourd'hui vous découvrez créer
une boîte de Pandore sociale et après on
va faire des cons dans le calendrier
quand on regarde les choses les 25 il y
a des gens qui vont être verbalisés
alors au niveau des feux potentiellement
potentiellement il y a des gens qui vont
verbaliser dans deux ans deux ans
comment les gens trouvent une
alternative d'ici là comment est-ce
qu'on leur explique 60% des gens
aujourd'hui sont pas au contraire par
rapport à ces arguments que vous portez
le risque bah une fois de plus d'être
taxé d'écologie punitive par une partie
de la population ça correspond aussi à
une réalité dans l'opinion oui c'est
relayé notamment par le rassemblement
national parce que je crois que notre
rôle d'élus c'est aussi un peu de de
d'expliquer ce qui ce qui est un peu
plus complexe notre rôle notre rôle
c'est pas d'être populiste
la pire des injustices ici
c'est la pollution de l'air parce que la
pollution de l'air elle touche les plus
précaires elle touche les enfants elle
touche les quartiers populaires et c'est
dans ces quartiers là et elle touche les
périphéries et c'est dans ces quartiers
là qui a des gens qui meurent
prématurément de la pollution de l'air
de Paris
vous avez beaucoup la parole dans les
quartiers périphériques sans souffrir de
la pollution et c'est ça le vrai sujet
en fait vous défendez pas du tout les
gens en luttant contre les éfe mais pas
du tout et le statu quo aujourd'hui il
est pas possible il est pas possible il
y a des gens qui meurent prématurément
de la pollution de l'air le l'État
français a été condamné plusieurs fois
pour son pour son incapacité à offrir un
air pur je dirais pour simplifier à ses
habitants et à ses habitants donc il
faut agir la ZFE c'est pas la solution
idéale changer tout le parc automobile
en et le transformer en parc électrique
mais personne ne dit ça et c'est pas une
solution écologique et là je vous
rejoins il y a pas de souci 2035
plus d'énergie fossiles ça veut pas dire
que ils vont tous être retirés de la
circulation non ces deux choses il faut
les ventes donc on est pas sur le même
calendrier et il y a effectivement des
propositions pour avoir une transition
qui soit plus écologique et qui respecte
en même temps la qualité de l'air et
rester au véhicule thermique et laisser
s'éteindre naturellement les véhicules
les plus polluants mais tout en
continuant à autoriser des véhicules
extrêmement lourds extrêmement gros de
plus en plus polluants etc ça n'est pas
la solution non plus
parce qu'on arrive au terme de ce débat
il y a un paradoxe
je dis qu'il faut trouver une position
médiane et nous ce qu'on porte depuis
des années des années des années
d'investir dans les transports
collectifs il y a des infrastructures
cyclables et je sais que ça marche pas
en ruralité mais il y a d'autres
propositions parce que 40 millions
d'automobilistes vous avez pas intérêt à
venir aussi avec vos propositions parce
que là on est quand même face à un
mouvement qui semble je sais pas combien
de temps j'ai mais juste rebondir deux
choses ça va être court déjà il faut
avoir une des vignettes critères les
vignettes critères elles sont sorties en
2016 sur un état de 2015 vous parlez
d'un paradoxe aujourd'hui je vais pas
citer de type de véhicules mais un super
des supercars faire des voitures très
puissantes souvent rouge par exemple ou
autre c'est les voitures qui ont le
droit à une vignette critère 1 Bienvenue
dans un centre-ville pourtant il y a un
paradoxe ils ont dit on arrive à trouver
un terrain de 48 €, ils ont des malus de
50000 €. mais par contre bienvenue dans
les centre-ville des comptes du Premier
ministre la majorité est prête à faire
bouger les choses l'histoire c'est que
moi je suis assez d'accord sur le
vignette critères et on le sait on en a
déjà une refonte après peut-être qu'avec
le système de de de commande de contrôle
justement le système lapic qui dit les
plaques d'immatriculation et qui vous
envoie directement sur les cartes grises
il y a quelque chose à travailler là
pour mettre effectivement les critères
de pollution sur les cartes grises et ça
nous permettrait en plus d'harmoniser
les choses pour finir dans les
propositions le contrôle technique on a
un contrôle technique sur l'automobile
qui a été renforcé sur la pollution en
2019 sur les particules normalement il y
a un contrôle technique qui doit être
ren sur les oxyde d'azote bientôt mais
là ils se mettent pas d'accord sur
l'appareil technique pour pouvoir le
faire donc à partir du moment où le
contrôle technique serait respecté ça
serait une solution aussi peut-être pour
sauver un an de plus ou deux ans de plus
certains véhicules qui ne pourront plus
entrer merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter on
va s'arrêter là on a bien compris que
c'est ZF on n'a pas fini d'en parler
c'est une certitude merci à tous les cas
d'être venu en débattre sur le plateau
de Savoie regarde on va s'intéresser à
présent à la Chine et à ses ambitions
pour ceux qui considèrent encore la
Chine comme l'atelier du monde un pays
dont la vocation serait de produire à
bas coût la plupart des produits que
nous consommons et bien sachez que ce
temps est bel et bien révolu on vous
propose de prendre le dernier vol pour
Pékin c'est le titre du dernier ouvrage
d'Alice seckman une invitation au voyage
et surtout à la réflexion Marion Becker
la lutte pour vous
si on vous invite Alice Eckman c'est
parce qu'on s'interroge que veut
creedjin Ping le président chinois
reconduit en octobre comme secrétaire
général du Parti communiste pour 5 ans
quels sont ses ambitions pour la Chine
si on vous pose la question à les segman
c'est parce que vous êtes reconnu comme
l'une des meilleures spécialistes de la
Chine et particulièrement de sa
politique intérieure et extérieure
docteur en sciences politiques vous êtes
aujourd'hui analyste responsable de
l'Asie à l'Institut d'études de sécurité
de l'Union européenne après rouge vif
l'idéal communiste vous publiez dernier
vol pour Pékin vous y racontez comment
XJ ping veut faire de la Chine la
première puissance mondiale et façonnée
un nouvel ordre mondial en se fermant à
l'Occident l'Occident pour le leader
chinois c'est cet ennemi qui selon lui
humilier la Chine qui est responsable
des grandes crises actuelles et qui veut
changer le système politique des pays
comme la Chine c'est avec ce message que
c'est Jin ping tente de séduire
l'Afrique l'Amérique latine et les pays
d'Asie du Sud-Est avec lesquels il a
renforcé ses liens depuis quelques
années et il entend
occupé une place dominante
nous avons promu la construction d'une
nouvelle forme de relation
internationale participer activement à
la réforme et à la construction du
système de gouvernance mondial lancer
pleinement la coopération internationale
pour lutter contre la pandémie et
remporter un large succès mondial
l'influence internationale de la Chine
son attrait et son pouvoir de façonner
le monde on considérablement augmenté
il se livre à une compétition de système
politique et joue sur la solidarité
entre pays non alignés avec les
Occidentaux comme la Russie ou l'Iran et
il entend ainsi bâtir une coalition
internationale alternative cette
compétition d'influence c'est ce que
vous appelez la bille mondialisation les
Occidentaux regardent avec attention et
vigilance la stratégie de xijing ping
ont-ils conscience que la Chine veut les
détrôner
bonsoir Alice ecmah bonsoir alors vous
êtes sinologue responsable de l'Asie à
l'institut d'étude de la sécurité de
l'Union européenne alors tout le monde
en tête à l'imperfite quand il a sorti
son livre quand la Chine s'éveillera
c'était une forme de mise en garde
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
l'Occident qui est un peu du mal à se
réveiller face à la Chine je reprends la
question que pose Marion Becker est-ce
que l'Europe notamment a pleinement
conscience que la Chine est devenue sans
doute son principal ennemi aujourd'hui
en tout cas son principal rival avec la
Russie vous vous souvenez de 2019 Union
européenne a publié une stratégie Chine
qualifiant la Chine à la fois de
partenaires de compétiteurs et de rivals
ce sont des mots mais depuis 2019
plusieurs points de tension ont émergé
entre la Chine et l'Union européenne
comme vous le savez tout d'abord la
crise pandémique a
fait prendre conscience notamment
européenne notamment au chef de la
diplomatie européenne Joseph Borel qu'il
s'agissait d'une qui avait une bataille
de des récits ou une guerre de
communication notamment sur sur la
communication autour du covid sur
l'assistance qui était qui était
déployée par la Chine notamment
l'assistance chinoise vis-à-visite
animée pour être plus concrète en
complément de ces divergence de
communication et il y a eu aussi des
divergences majeures sur la question de
cynthiang
divergence donc politique et la question
de droits de l'homme qui a mis entre
parenthèses
l'accord sur les investissements vous
savez que il y a plus de 2 ans a été
négocié au bout de six ans un accord sur
les investissements entre la Chine Union
européenne qui suite à des sanctions de
l'Union européenne touchant des
officiels chinois ayant pris part la
politique de répression au cimetière et
des contresensions prises
cet accord a été mis entre parenthèses
on est dans des décisions diplomatiques
on va dire quand les États-Unis par
Donald Trump qui a quand même été assez
lucide là-dessus durant son mandat les
aux Etats-Unis ont pris des mesures
beaucoup plus radicales contre la Chine
on a l'impression que l'Europe a peur
face à la Chine
non l'approche est très différente
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu divergent sur
le fond il y a quand même une
convergence
d'analyse sur un durcissement de la
politique intérieure extérieure chinoise
évidente il y a pas de naïveté
européenne moi j'en constate pas au sein
des États membres on a aussi une
convergence sur la perception de la
Chine notamment aussi depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine avec une prise de
conscience que que la Chine ne s'est pas
distancée vis-à-vis de de son partenaire
russe loin de là depuis le début de la
guerre donc il y a quelques divergences
entre États allemands mais globalement
la convergence est là il est cassé aussi
une convergence transatlantique soit
analyse sur la méthode Donald Trump
fait le choix d'une politique de
sanction assez forte qui n'a d'ailleurs
ne touche pas que des entreprises
chinoises mais en premier des
entreprises chinoises notamment dans
cette technologie et politique de
sanctions et contre sanctions côté
chinois l'Union européenne considère
qu'il faut être vigilant elle n'est pas
contre les sanctions elle-même elle en a
prises d'ailleurs vis-à-vis de la Chine
mais elles a pas étendu au domaine
technologique de
[Musique]
machine comme puissance numéro 1 à
l'échéance 2050 pour les centenaires de
la création de la République populaire
de Chine et on l'a vu réellement dans le
lancement d'initiative multiple
c'est-à-dire qu'il a lancé les nouvelles
routes de la soie il a lancé un certain
nombre de concepts comme communauté de
destins communs etc et il a multiplié
les rencontres bilatérales les forums
multilatéraux notamment avec des pays
d'Europe centrale et orientale
d'ailleurs forum aujourd'hui qui bat de
l'aile suite aussi avec des tensions
concernant avec la Lituanie mais
globalement sheeting est dans une
diplomatie qui est à l'initiative il a
renforcé le réseau diplomatiques chinois
aujourd'hui c'est le premier réseau
diplomatico au monde en termes de nombre
d'ambassadeurs très dur on l'a vu par
exemple avec l'ambassadeur de Chine en
France qui fait partie de
comment on les appelle les loups
combattants lou shy qui s'est permis
parfois d'insulter ouvertement la France
en tout cas des ressortissants français
quel est quelle est la logique de cette
forme de diplomatie
tout d'abord c'est pas uniquement le
fait d'un ambassadeur on note cette
dynamique
de diplomate chinois emmené par le
fraction divergente c'est-à-dire c'est
une orientation officielle soutenue par
le gouvernement central c'est pas dû à
la personnalité de celle ou un tel c'est
une stratégie coordonnée de diplomatie
offensive qui vise à accepter aucune
critique venant de pays ou institutions
considérés comme potentiellement style
mais surtout de riposter
systématiquement
y compris au niveau officiel on était
non diplomatique mais il faut bien
prendre en compte le fait que cette
diplomatie des loups combattants touche
les pays occidentaux et en parallèle la
Chine continue à mener une diplomatie
qu'on pourrait qualifier de séduction
vis-à-vis des pays dit en développement
et émergeant c'est à dire que l'Occident
qui est l'ennemi les pays qu'elle
considère critique sur les droits de
l'homme le cimetière la mère de Chine du
Sud avec des objectifs de politique
intérieure vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique chinoise quelque part c'est ce
que dit louche à lui-même le standard
pour évaluer notre travail n'est pas la
façon dont les étrangers nous voient
mais comment les gens ont Chine nous
voient c'est c'est étonnant comme
conception des diplomaties oui mais il
faut pas en tirer la conclusion que la
politique étrangère chinoise d'une
variable
une variable de la politique intérieure
chinoise bien sûr qu'il y a des liens
c'est la c'est la prolongation des
orientations politiques intérieures mais
ce n'est pas des voilà des dérapages de
communication pour faire plaisir à la
frange nationaliste de la population non
c'est une communication qui est
pleinement en dossier par sitting et qui
est clairement de dire que l'Occident
n'a plus à critiquer la Chine mais n'a
plus non plus à façonner les
organisations multilatérales
et qu'il est temps aujourd'hui
finalement de les marginaliser c'est à
dire que la Chine considère aujourd'hui
mais on avance comment j'appelle une
diplomatie comptable en cessant de
[Musique]
considéré comme des petits États comme
les îles Salomon ou d'autres alors
justement est-ce que pour convaincre
pour séduire ils offrent un modèle
politique à ces pays un système de
valeurs un mode de gouvernance qui
pourrait les séduire on a du mal à voir
ça vu de l'Occident en tout cas oui mais
ce qui est intéressant quand même de
noter que ce modèle considère que ça
rivalité avec le silence premier
États-Unis est une rivalité systémique
elle-même elle le considère contre
l'Occident mais pas par adhésion à des
principes ou des valeurs que la Chine
défendrait c'est alors elle ne parle pas
de valeur elle parle de stabilité
politique c'est un argument qui peut
séduire des régimes autoritaires qui
cherchent à rester stable justement elle
part d'opposition révolution de couleur
c'est à dire aux mobilisation populaire
qu'elle considère qu'ils peuvent
conduire fomenter par l'Occident au sens
large sous une approche relativement
conspirationniste des crises et puis
clairement elle a des atouts les
arguments technologiques la 5G 4G les
câbles sous-marins les datacenters
au niveau des grandes infrastructures
des communications mais au niveau aussi
est terminé les smartphones etc et cette
compétition ne doit pas être
sous-estimée parce que elle est
attractive aux yeux d'une partie du
monde il y a quand même quelques loupés
si on peut dire dans cette stratégie
d'affirmation de la Chine on en a vu un
récemment avec l'échec on peut le dire
de la stratégie zéro covid est-ce que
c'est un échec personnel pour oxygène
ping est-ce que ça le fragilise
politiquement
l'ajustement de la politique zéro covid
a beaucoup étonné tellement elle
semblait finalement
figée dans le marbre immuable donc
clairement les manifestations les
mobilisations dans la rue dans plusieurs
villes du pays non seulement ont étonné
par leur slogans qui ont dépassé la
remise en cause la politique zéroville
par contre la liberté d'expression tout
simplement mais aussi c'est la justement
de cette politique qui peut étonner
aujourd'hui mais il n'y a pas de remise
en cause générale et profonde de la
politique mise en place même s'il y a
des ajustements significatifs
la politique de CD n'est pas remise en
cause le maillage géographique du parti
n'est pas remise en cause même si bien
sûr il y a une levée de certains outils
comme les codes QR etc donc c'est
intéressant une période intéressante à
noter c'est à justement qui peut étonner
en même temps nous sommes nous étions
arrivés à un tel degré de de zèle de la
part des autorité locale sous pression
des gouvernement central notamment dans
le test de légumes de poissons on avait
et puis aussi des résidences barricadées
des inconfinement extrêmement strict à
Shanghai en avril mai dernier que la oui
et que la population a finalement a
réagi malgré les risques qu'elle encourt
dans cette réaction il faut pas le faut
pas sous-est aujourd'hui la répression
la répression des manifestations est une
réalité et de fait les manifestations se
sont estompées dans les rues des grandes
villes si on regarde aussi un autre
point faible si l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas l'état
de l'économie chinoise fragilisée par le
zéro covid fragilisé aussi par cette
crise financière liée au secteur
immobilier
est-ce que est-ce que la Chine a
vraiment les moyens de ses ambitions
aujourd'hui on a du mal à mesurer l'état
réel de l'économie chinoise on a eu
différents indicateurs vous avez raison
de souligner la crise de l'immobilier
qui est significative et qui a eu aussi
des conséquences sur les épargnants par
significatif de gens en fait ont acheté
deux futurs immeubles qui n'existeront
jamais par ils ont des emprunts à
rembourser voilà
tout le monde mais une participation de
la population en parallèle à cela il y a
l'impact de la politique zéro covid et
de la crise pandémique sur la croissance
qui a nettement ralenti on parle de
l'avantage de 3% que que 6 % observé il
y a quelques années et puis il y a aussi
ce cette nouvelle approche cette perte
de confiance des acteurs économiques
loto et internationaux sur les
perspectives à long terme c'est-à-dire
que les multinationales se retirées
progressivement de la Chine alors que
c'était un marché
qui faisait rêver toutes les grandes
entreprises de l'Occident le marché
chinois n'est plus considéré comme un
eldorado par beaucoup d'entreprises
étrangères même si ça reste un marché
important et il y a des stratégies qui
se mettent en place des réflexions
stratégiques sur la diversification des
zones de production par exemple c'est un
entreprises de secteur stratégiques mais
progressivement bon la Chine reste la
deuxième puissance économique mondiale
le ralentissement économique est une
chose mais pour l'instant notre pas en
tout cas d'ajustement des ambitions de
politique étrangères chinois on a vu
récemment setting participer à la
version de coopération de Shanghai à
recevoir le gouvernement pakistanais
récemment se développer ce pardon se
rendre en Arabie Saoudite donc on a
vraiment l'activisme merci beaucoup
Alice Eckman il y a beaucoup de choses
encore et vous évoqué dans votre livre
dernier vol pour Pékin notamment ce
concept de bimondialisation on n'a pas
le temps d'en parler malheureusement
mais vous restez avec nous parce qu'on
accueille à présent nos affranchis avec
notamment Marco pommier qui va revenir
sur l'affaire Adrien Catena on verra
avec Fanny guinochet ce que vaut cette
taxe carbone qui va voir le jour aux
frontières de l'Europe enfin Isabelle
Lasserre qui est arrivé qui s'installe
nous expliquera pourquoi on est
malheureusement très loin d'un plan de
paix entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
bonsoir à tous les trois bons vous allez
bien tout le monde va bien bon on
commence avec vous Marco marque ce soir
vont nous parler de l'embarras de la
France insoumise le groupe qui a donc
décidé de suspendre son député Adrien
catenens après sa condamnation hier pour
violence conjugale oui Clément
condamnation par le tribunal de Lille 4
mois de prison avec sursis et 2000 euros
de dommages et intérêts pour violences
conjugale vous le disiez en septembre
souvenez-vous Adrien catenin ce avait
reconnu avoir giflé son épouse il avait
donc plaidé coupable hier dans la foulée
de cette condamnation la France
insoumise publie un communiqué nous
avons pris la décision de suspendre
Adrien catenens de notre groupe
suspension donc mais pas exclusion
écoutez Antoine Léo membre de la France
insoumise il justifie cette décision
politique
cette décision là c'est une décision qui
est très dure je veux que tout le monde
en est bien conscience je crois qu'aucun
groupe n'a à ce jour pris une décision
aussi dure pour des cas de ce type pour
moi il est aussi normal qu'il puisse y
avoir une période dans laquelle il
revient et dans laquelle il puisse
exercer le mandat pour lequel il a été
élu voilà un pas d'exclusion mais une
suspension avec radiation pour quatre
mois jusqu'au 13 avril 2023 la France
insoumise qui conditionne aussi le
retour d'Adrien catenin dans son groupe
un stage de responsabilisation sur les
violences faites aux femmes auprès d'une
association féministe une décision qui
est loin de faire l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée de quoi donner un angle
d'attaque à la majorité présidentielle
Prisca theveno adressée hier à la France
insoumise un carton rouge
on a tout simplement la France insoumise
qui droit dans ses bottes sans trembler
nous dit que eux sont sur des mesures
temporaires provisoires que pouvons-nous
dire de ces députés qui aujourd'hui nous
font des grandes leçons de morale à
crier en permanence à faire du bruit sur
tout mais quand il s'agit d'agir ils
agissent faibles voilà un pas de cadeau
pour les insoumis et même dans la nupes
la décision ne fait pas l'unanimité face
caméra certains n'hésitent pas à prendre
position Adrien catenas devrait-il être
exclu de la France insoumise doit-il
démissionner de son mandat de député
écouter les réponses
la question elle est politique et
éthiques elle est posée Adrien est-il en
situation de défendre la cause commune
ou est-elle en situation d'abîmer la
force dont nous avons besoin notamment
pour s'opposer à la réforme des
retraites je pense que aujourd'hui n'est
plus en situation de le faire et si
Adrien catenin avait été aux partis
socialiste nous l'aurions exclu du
groupe
qu'il se représente devant les électeurs
électriques puisque le contrat par
lequel il a été élu quelque part n'est
plus le même on a envie de savoir Marco
qu'est-ce qu'il en dit lui-même Adrien
Catena c'est ce qu'il est prêt à
démissionner et ben non un Clément pas
question pour lui de démissionner
rappelons que lui seul peut prendre
cette décision en tant que député élu
dans la voie du Nord ce matin Adrien
catenin se parle d'un acharnement
disproportionné il persiste et signe ce
soir sur BFM TV
encore une fois si j'avais été
l'auteur de violences répétées si la
question ce serait posée là c'est
différent pour moi et puis surtout si je
le faisais bruste tout ça réfléchissait
un instant on parle depuis tout à
l'heure de la confusion qu'il peut y
avoir entre
la vie privée et la politique la justice
et les médias si je démissionnais demain
ce sera un précédent à mon avis assez
dangereux qui ouvrirait la voix à toute
instrumentalisation de la vie privée en
politique voilà et Adrien ce qui annonce
aussi son intention de retourner à
l'Assemblée nationale dès le mois de
janvier en tant que non inscrits il est
temps que je reprenne mon activité
parlementaire à Tilly de très près des
mois de janvier merci Marco pommier on
passe à vous Fanny guinochet bonsoir
journaliste à France Info alors l'Europe
vient de se doter d'une taxe carbone aux
frontières enfin on a envie de dire
enfin ça faisait longtemps qu'on en
parlait en Europe dans l'Union 15 ans
quasiment et en plus c'est une première
mondiale il faut quand même le saluer
alors l'idée c'est quoi c'est d'imposer
les importations de l'Union européenne
dans 5 secteurs les secteurs qui sont
les plus polluants l'acier le ciment
l'aluminium le faire les engrais et ces
secteurs et bien ils seront ces produits
seront taxés en fonction du bilan
environnemental de leur production mais
aussi en fonction d'un prix européen de
notre tonne de carbone alors autrement
dit on fait payer les pollueurs
étrangers c'est un principe louable
c'est un principe plutôt fondé
maintenant il faut voir ce qu'il va
donner il s'agit aussi de préserver
l'industrie européenne vous avez raison
parce que évidemment quand vous faites
rentrer un produit qui est a été réalisé
sans préserver les normes
environnementales en général il est
moins cher donc il y a une concurrence
déloyale avec nos industries et cette
taxe doit normalement rééquilibrer les
choses et puis on va pas non plus se
mentir elle doit rapporter 14 milliards
d'euros en ce moment à un moment où
l'Europe cherche de l'argent ça fait du
bien alors c'est 14 milliards d'euros ça
c'est sur le papier mais si on regarde
les détails tout n'est pas encore réglé
et bien oui parce que ça c'est le
principe mais le mécanisme d'application
le diable se cache dans les détails et
très très compliqué parce que par
exemple on ne sait pas comment on va
calculer le bilan environnemental d'un
engrais produit en Chine ou au Brésil je
vous mets au défi d'y parvenir et puis
la limite du système c'est qu'on ne va
taxer que les produits bruts les
matériaux bruts et pas du tout les
produits finis donc il y a certains
certaines entreprises qui pourront faire
rentrer en Europe des produits finis
avec mais en ayant utilisé des matériaux
qui ne correspondent pas aux normes
environnementales et puis aussi le
moment qui a été choisi alors là c'est
le plus problématique en fait parce que
cette taxe elle arrive à un moment où
l'Europe est affaiblie sur la scène des
investissements internationaux elle est
affaiblie notamment par rapport aux
Européens aux Américains pardon et les
américains ils n'y vont pas par quatre
chemins Joe Biden déverse des milliards
d'euros à l'industrie sous forme de
subventions pour aider les entreprises
les groupes américains à ce verdir et là
nous de l'autre côté on met une
contraintes là où normalement c'est taxe
elle est essentielle nous aider et bien
on risque de nous fragiliser nous-mêmes
c'est-à-dire de se tirer une balle dans
le pied même si le principe on le répète
est plutôt et plutôt louable merci
beaucoup Fanny guinochet Alice ecman
juste sur le principe même de cette taxe
carbone c'est une taxe qui vise
notamment la Chine et ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à des mesures de rétorsion en
quelques mots juste
peut-être il est trop tôt pour savoir
réellement mais c'est sûr c'est que ça
va avoir des conséquences sérieuses
significatives sur les exportations
chinoises et c'est déjà au cœur des
discussions des relations ambilatérales
France Chine mais aussi Union européenne
Chine la mise en application de cet
article carbone qui passe par la
répétition du message aux entreprises
chinoises à l'État chinois pour qu'elles
comprennent bien que maintenant voilà il
va falloir prendre en compte
[Musique]
mental et intégrer pleinement et
respecter pleinement cette nouveauté ces
nouvelles décisions c'est à VOUS
Isabelle Lasserre volo dix meilleurs
élèves qui a présenté il y a un mois un
plan de paix en 10 points alors est-ce
que ce plan est réaliste est-ce qui est
ce qu'il peut comme certains l'espère à
aboutir à une fin prochaine du conflit
de la guerre avec la Russie alors à long
terme oui il est sans doute réalisé
parce que quand on compare d'un côté la
violence de l'agression russe les
délires impérialistes du Kremlin les
crimes de guerre et les piètres
performances de l'armée russe et qu'en
face on voit la résilience
extraordinaire de la population
ukrainienne
les succès incroyables de de son armée
sont sa volonté aussi de se payer à
rejoindre le camp européen on se dit que
la meilleure sortie de la guerre c'est
le point numéro 6 du plan de paix
présidentielle c'est-à-dire le retrait
des troupes russes de tous les
territoires occupés annexés et la
récupération par l'Ukraine de sa
souveraineté nationale c'est-à-dire en
gros une victoire de l'Ukraine une
défaite de la Russie avec un en prime
espère certains la chute de la maison
Poutine pour pouvoir ensuite repartir
sur de meilleures bases avec Moscou et
ce scénario qui réalise à court terme il
est aussi à long terme pardon il est
aussi totalement inapplicable à court
terme alors pourquoi alors parce que la
Russie malgré c'est déclarations sur une
possible paix n'est prête à aucune
concession dénégociations oui dit Moscou
mais à condition que l'Ukraine
reconnaisse l'annexion des territoires
conquis et occupés par la Russie en fait
le régime russe n'a aucun plein plan de
paix en poche et il a toujours les mêmes
objectifs faire plier l'Ukraine le chute
de l'Ukraine indépendante où sa
destruction si elle ne veut pas se
soumettre à Moscou le problème c'est que
pour l'instant la Russie on l'a vu n'a
pas les moyens de ses ambitions alors
que l'ukraino contraire devient chaque
jour plus forte et plus déterminé alors
on a vu que les
Occident soutient l'Ukraine mais est-ce
que ce soutien est durable dans le temps
on voit que cette guerre elle a des
conséquences économiques on voit qu'il y
a aussi une forme de fatigue de la part
d'une partie de la population alors
c'est la bonne surprise de ces derniers
jours le plan de paix de velody
mirzelenski il a été validé à la fois
par Joe Biden et par Emmanuel Macron
après avoir longtemps hésité la Maison
Blanche a aussi décidé de fournir des
missiles patriotes à l'Ukraine pour
qu'elle puisse se défendre contre les
bombardements russes depuis l'armée
depuis le début de la guerre on l'a vu
l'armée ukrainienne a fait ses preuves
elle a montré aussi sa combativité et
aussi la manière dont elle utilisait
absolument parfaitement toutes les
livraisons d'armes qui qui lui sont
fournies alors malgré l'inquiétude et
les difficultés l'Europe et les
États-Unis pour l'instant tienne bon la
conférence de soutien à l'Ukraine hier à
rassembler un milliard d'euros à Paris
et selon plusieurs sources les
fournitures d'armes américaines se
poursuivront de toute façon jusqu'à la
fin du printemps les Ukrainiens eux ont
l'intention d'aller vite très vite merci
beaucoup Isabelle Lasserre Alice ecman
sur ce sujet aussi on a envie d'entendre
un peu votre point de vue on a du mal à
mesurer à quel point la Chine soutient
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui notamment
sur cette guerre en Ukraine dans le
sentiment que Pékin est comme moi
passablement agacé par les conséquences
économiques de cette guerre
on note pas de distanciation de Pékin
vis-à-vis de Moscou ça ne veut pas dire
mais on n'a pas de soutien affiché non
plus si enfin une augmentation des
importations d'hydrocarbures en
provenance de Russie la Russie est le
premier exportateur le premier
fournisseur de pétrole à la Chine depuis
juin on note un soutien diplomatique de
la Chine qui a fait déployer tous ces
une énergie pour maintenir la Chine dans
certaines enceintes multilatérales elles
sont de coopération de Shanghai les
BRICS le G20 même si ça faisait pas
déplacer à Bali mais on a réellement une
volonté chinoise de d'éviter que la
Russie soit un état paria on a la
prolongation d'exercice militaire
conjoint il y a un soutien
le nucléaire non le nucléaire est en
effet la question il faut voilà la
question nucléaire clairement est
à l'agent voilà est une source de
préoccupation pour pour la partie
chinoise et puis de manière générale
voilà la Chine ne souhaite pas une
escalade militaire encore plus forte que
celle que l'on note mais il n'y a pas
distanciation et clairement le
renforcement des liens commerciaux
énergétiques entre la Chine et la Russie
a pour conséquence directe de limiter
l'impact des sanctions ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils sanctions n'ont pas
d'efficacité mais quand globalement il
faut voilà il faut prendre en compte le
fait que le partenariat stratégique que
la Chine est la Russie ont signé le 4
février n'est pas remise en question
merci beaucoup Alice ecman merci à tous
les trois également c'est la fin de
cette émission demain vous retrouverez
Myriam mankawa pour un nouveau numéro de
savouregarde tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire à très bientôt sur SCP
[Musique]